il est 13h le marathon d'une journée
ordinaire de christophe leroy se
poursuit nous sommes ici au polo club de
gassin qui s'ajoute aux multiples autres
établissements dans lesquels il apporte
sa griffe à bouger à avoriaz à marrakech
à saint tropez
pourtant le cuisinier se défend d'être
devenu un homme d'affaires
tu nous fais plein de petites entrées tu
le fais goûter un plat de chaque pour
tous ok allez pour ce soir êtes prêt
compare souvent mon métier un homme de
théâtre qui jouent une pièce à un moment
qui ont une autre c'est ça et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de faire des endroits
des équipes défend une cuisine la
gourmandise à toute heure à tout moment
évidemment je défends pas la même
cuisine à la montagne que celle t à
marrakech que ce rigole que sélection
interne paulo que leurs habits straw en
place entre ville viscéralement
cuisinier certes mais un cuisinier qui
aime aussi la fête et donc les artistes
et ce n'est pas un hasard s'il a repris
les fameuses soirées blanches des 10
marques les même s'il réfute sur
l'étiquette showbiz je crois que dès
qu'on fait un peu quelque chose on est
mis dans une case ou lors de cette
étiquette le showbiz c'est ce qui me
plaît du showbiz c'est que ces gens sont
des gens très vrai très sympa et qui
raconte qui par leur vie professionnelle
vers raconte vraiment une histoire il
vit vraiment leur façon jusqu'au bout
qu'ils soient chanteurs comédiens ou au
tout artiste quand on refait le monde
avec eux jusqu'à trois heures du matin
avec la isla qui se mettent sur les
imitations il se met à chanter moi j'ai
eu johnny chante et davy crockett à 5
heures du matin peux vous assurer que ça
vaut tout spectacle mais au delà des
paillettes christophe leroy reste fidèle
à sa vocation originelle à son premier
établissement qui l'a gardé même si cet
homme pressé voit toujours devant et le
train qui passe i thought dedans il
attrape les wagons et il ya ce 3 et pour
moi les ports pour un autre un peu comme
ça un baroudeur toujours en mouvement
qui a décidé de ne pas courir les
étoiles des guides de créer un
laboratoire un cow-boy l'un pour avoir
une structure à la main
de ce metteur en fait boulimique capable
de décor et n'importe quel lieu d'où ce
dernier rêve
ça fait longtemps que j'ai envie de te
construire un espèce de dorado qui sera
à 20 mètres du bord de mer et que ça
serait une vraie scène et où les gens
dînerait dessus se tient juste une
passerelle et que le personnel irl et
serviable est un peu comme un enfant qui
s'amuse défini manger c'est exactement
ça j'ai pas sûr que jamais je mets
équipe à tout instant mais en tout cas
moi oui
[Musique]